hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to pray now we're back
in the neuro mod division because
there's one thing we forgot to do while
we were here but first Oh God
nailed it okay so in here we need to
make we need to meet with egg way so
that we can I don't know rip some neuro
mods out a doll which is something
always fun to do so I'm gonna bring Mike
you got oh hey how's it going in here
hello Doctor you uh-huh yeah I was
afraid you wouldn't make it
uh-huh the subject though has been
secured he seems however isolated the
correct neural mod it is essential we
say as little as possible of what has
happened on the station and focus on the
situation doll memory serves should
resort to field training and react
accordingly he was never one to question
orders about that oh looks see nothing
oh okay alright then perform Narada me
ah wait what happens if I engage the
surgical harness when extracted those
memories should revert back to the
inception date and he should forget his
assignment here hang on neural scan new
mogan
Hey
uh-huh okay debrief oh ah okay all right
here we go I'm getting it ready when you
are
oof suck it out of his brain get rid of
all that [ __ ] what who are you
Morgan your father's been asking about
you and Alex it was supposed to report
to him about her retrieval after malting
up where am i why am i restrained
commander oh uh
I am dr. ego a chief physician here you
I've seen your face in the company
directory alex is at the discredited
parapsychologist commander doll you
suffered a severe head injury as a
result of a crisis here on the station
we need to evacuate at once but we we
couldn't leave without you you're a
great actor man able to pilot the
shuttle what yes of course I can pilot
wait what emergency
is this Argus installation where's
Casper I'm afraid there's no time to
explain
we need to get to the shuttle bay and
prepare for departure transed our
mandate doctor you can confirm of course
Morgan you look like [ __ ] thanks man all
right let's get daddy's precious child
off the station tranced our black box me
oh okay
thank you check your vitals wouldn't
want our pilot to faint there's nothing
wrong with me
can I talk to you blah blah blah blah
blah blah
I got Typhon in my blood blah blah blah
blah shut it in my I got it in my brain
blah blah blah ripped it out of your
head what you're going to do this turn
of events with Dahle I'm impressed and
surprised you've managed to find a way
to get remaining the room off the
station
we've got you I have no doubt they'll
remember your sacrifice hmm yeah my
sacrifice well hey that's kind of good
Oh Luther glass oh I guess I can't do
that anymore
oh oh well Luther glass isn't gonna be
here anymore well that's sad I didn't I
didn't think there was anything that I
could have done for him anyway but it
seems like I've already been through
here and I can do a little bit of a fix
up but anyway that's the last thing we
need to do and just in case I think what
this means just in case we blow up the
place that means that we can you know
you might not want to do that when he's
your ride out of here so I think I think
as far as I know save Ronnie killed the
tie fun that was controlling Ronnie and
the others Oh
oh yeah that's right okay go dolls gonna
contact me from the shuttle and I need
to go to the Arboretum anyway for all of
that it's goopy and then we just need to
go through here and we need to go back
to the Arboretum which means we need to
fly the center of all that [ __ ] in
the lobby and then go to the end I have
a funny feeling this game is gonna end
with me fighting a gigantic Typhon
monstrosity no matter what I do a lot
dead space that was my favorite thing
about dead space one was the giant giant
frickin thing popping out of the ground
there and then crushing it with a giant
piece of rock no more brutal way to kill
something than that
Vidia hoo-ha no one sees me no one sees
me no one sees me Hey
Oh miss me baby okay I just need to go
up here and then I need to take care of
everything that I need to take care of
and hopefully that means I'm gonna be
okay
probably does it but you know one can
hope one can always hope
here we go so oh oh yeah that's uh it's
an idiot waiting for things to happen
that are gonna happen any day now let's
go do ski okay so I mean it really comes
down to this I just gotta go meet Alex
and maybe talk to Ronnie on the way but
I really just got to go meet with Alex
and get the arming key and then decide
whether to blow this whole sumbitch up
don't I I mean that's what it amounts to
that's what we've been working towards
this whole time so I mean why not it's
gonna be a tough decision
I mean or maybe it's not because it
seems like the ultimate end of this is
that the Typhon are [ __ ] unstoppable
so you gotta blow em up where you can oh
oh I need to go up there oh this babe
miss me whoa slide miss me all right
sweet
ah slide yeah
oh that was awesome
did I get any of his goop left was all
of his goop gone seems like all of his
goop might be gone
hello anybody in here
I'm very alive huh well I guess there
are no one here
might as well keep going then oh boy
someone's coming up about to get I like
this gun I like it's got a lot I wish I
knew whoa whoa Nellie this is awesome
this is awesome
all right maybe I could use it to take
care of that guy I just want to see if
it works out well we just first no no no
let's just use small little things on
you guys okay just wanted to be sure Wow
shockingly effective why have I not been
using that the whole time point Hey
thank you I'll take the cubm cells
because I love those all right so now we
just got to go meet up with Alex and not
get shocked by this thing so let's do
that all right
oh you don't need to bother me I don't
need to bother you you don't need to
bother me
all right I guess it comes down to this
is weird weird I don't know what Ronnie
went Bo Hey
no you can come up here and with my aq
beam
Oh neato neato burrito trick dude it's
good it's really cool
this gun is really cool man I could have
been taken out so many big things I'll
save it in case there's a boss later but
alright
I don't know why I don't know why I'm
prepping up to fight ow it's here let's
take my glue gun
this isn't he did spread some extra glue
in here Alex Alex Alex where are you
you're in the wall Alex oh I know where
you are skinning ski Alex what what what
huh well that doesn't make any sense
what's going on here oh really what he's
been there the whole time what the hell
I promised you my arm in Cape all I ask
is you hear me out first okay and you
can blow Paolo's one to pieces if that's
what you think is best
okay I don't think you'll do it I know
because I used to think we couldn't be
trusted to play with fire without
burning the house down but you convinced
me
you showed me anything was possible even
if the price was steep that part of you
is still in there we can make history
Morgan but those leeches on the Transtar
Board of Directors not mom and dad you
and I just like we planned
we're at the data to confirm what you
suspected coral is broadcasting a neural
signal secret message reaching to the
stars what I want to know is what is the
message and who is listening to it I
think you know ever since we first
tested the typhoon euro mods you've
known
his fabrication plan is for the null
wave device prototype you can see it
will hijack the coral signal and use it
to deliver a massive shock there every
type and organism at once take it okay
the army key okay pour what oh god what
oh hi whoa whoa Ronnie Oh No oh I knew
it I knew it
oh I knew it giant tiny fun
oh hi hi oh hi oh hi Alex you all right
there buddy whoa hey whoa what the [ __ ]
is unconscious how did that happen
hang on come here whoa Alex where'd you
go whoa what is that whoa whoa whoa whoa
holy [ __ ] man I gotta get him in the
door right
how am i carrying him come here you Mary
you I'm gonna carry you into this whoa
where am i where am i where am i where
am i where am i where am i where did I
go okay there we go I need to get him in
the safe room get Alex get to Alex
before he dies I know that I've got him
he's here he's floating with me so he
needs to go into safe from aah it's dark
in here oh I see I see I see I see okay
so we got to put him there he's fine I
think all right so I need to use I'll
take this I'm gonna take this and take
the cola that's you can have the food I
guess you could take the pistol to I
don't want to take everything from an
account of Fermi's questions considering
that there are billion stars in the
galaxy if a civilizations before ours it
seems so oh yeah the Fermi paradox all
right Alex you have fun in there when
the gravity turns back on I'm sure
you'll do fine oh brother mine
go to ski okay
so he's in there so he's locked up real
tight whoa
well it seems bad okay okay all right
then
as soon as gravity turns back on or
something okay so this is it I can
either are gonna either blow everything
to [ __ ] or I can you know yeah yeah let
me just review my options and the
objectives here mind without limits
fabricate the null-void device or self
destructs yeah so uh pull me these where
it really comes down to do i do i trust
in the idea that this no wave device the
prototype is even gonna work or do i
just blow it all up i mean even if i
blow it all up would it actually stop
anything that's my main question because
it's not something that is specifically
targeting the Typhon but this no wave
device seems it just is disrupt though
[Music]
maybe if i do both maybe I can do both
because it doesn't say the one is
exclusive to the other I can always put
the no wave device there and then also
blow it up
if that don't work maybe I'm gonna try
that one because it seems I don't know
it seems like there's a lot of like
crazy stuff going on here and there's a
lot of options go through it but I do
want to try to fabricate this reactor
console down there and I don't know
where the other objective is hey
military operator Oh Nellie it's sorry
to get my bearings here sorry you guys
are oh hey hi buddy
pool boy okay bye all right fine then
Jesus and I'm just gonna try to get down
to the ground I need to find a
fabricator no matter what if I'm gonna
build this in the first place yes yeah
that's super weird I wonder if that
could kill me probably anyway I'm gonna
find a fabricator as best I can
I think there's a fabricator down here
in deep storage I think there is pretty
sure either way I'm gonna be back once
I've maybe not because I can't go that
way never mind that was all a bunch of
lies I'm not gonna go that way then I
guess I'm gonna go there's probably a
fabricator down by the reactor so at
least I can make the decision to do it
there because it oh because it's either
one or the other right
Oh God oh no no no no no no Jesus being
in zero gravity is more hazardous than I
thought for different reasons
thank you other serious emergency his
report to the nearest luster station
uh-huh Oh muster station means [ __ ]
come on scoop it gloop it okay there we
go yes yes yes all right either way I'm
gonna go down here because I know this
fabricators down here and I bet it's
kind of guiding me along to either go to
the reactor console or to the null wave
I'm surprised that January has not any
opinion on the null wave device
considering he's kind of got my brain in
him but only to a certain extent though
and I just don't know what to do like
what what could it all lead to like what
would one do versus the other there's no
point in standing around dissipated the
kind of Appeal Alex would make sibling
bonds history you program me to refute
him point by point however we can skip
that mmm the size of a skyscraper is
currently eating Talos 1 for lunch
ergo Alex is wrong destroy the station
just as you planned the blast will take
the monster down with it destroy the
station but alex is correct
good work and preserve what we have
learned here we have to try of course
it's a risk but we've seen the generator
work to destroy it all this to mother
species research
first huh well set it up for both I
guess you never know did I get some
opinions we don't have much time Morgan
wait talk to me I disagree strongly with
people who advocate for the removal of
instructive consequences because they
want to live in a world where no
personal pleasure is ever denied this is
it either you destroy tell us one or
that creature destroys us bargain okay
coming down to that huh yeah it words
for this know you got nothing okay all
right then I'll just make this decision
on my own then no help for anybody oh
boy
so my thought is destruction is the most
certain method of getting rid of
everything it would be the most
definitive way to ensure that these
things off I probably unless man unless
actually the null wave is something
that's going to actually help more but
my thought is my thought is that it my
thought is that I don't know like
honestly I don't know there's no real
rational way like both have the
positives in the negatives so it's kind
of hard to determine which is actually
gonna work
so if I need to go down to I'm guessing
I need to go down to oh I needed to die
I needed to make the damn thing Frick a
dick I hope it didn't use up all my
materials so I'm gonna have to
disassemble something I don't want to
disassemble oh but if I make the thing
and then place it somewhere I guess
maybe it's going to be okay or at least
it will give me the option all right
let's see this thing chloral detector
prototype no wave of course so now I got
to disassemble some [ __ ] here
my trusty wrench nah these nah this I
don't have enough of that one this one
no no no that Oh brick what can i
disassemble spare parts I've got a lot
of spare parts I can I can I can split
some of those all right that's good
enough all right let's put that in there
[Music]
okay so we're making the prototype no
wave transmitter we're just making it we
don't know for certain ah not very
impressive I guess okay so oh I don't
know hey it's dark outside I'm gonna
place it there it doesn't mean that it
gets set off I'm just gonna place it I'm
just gonna place it and see what they've
tell me because they're gonna talk me
through this at least I'm gonna have a
little bit more info before I actually
commit because you have to detonate it
from the bridge no matter what you do
and I'm just gonna see if it's one or
exclusive or the other god I hated that
I hate that it doesn't give you like one
that's morally better than the other
because both have positives and
negatives it just all depends on whether
you trust technology enough to target
specifically the Typhon I guess it
wouldn't completely outright kill the
time
what would happen if you scan DX all
your models point to suffering oh boy if
you scan the apex like what does that
even mean hi oh oh wow how did that
happen
oh I wasn't ready for that how we stop
it stop it
yeesh oh boy okay moving around along
let me repair my suit a little bit oh
[ __ ] a duck
this is getting pretty dank in here Oh
time for Q bean no not that that's not
what I wanted
Oh where'd you go where'd you go where'd
he go all right we got that frickin dick
oh hi what are you still doing here
Aaron hey can me this stared at the wall
Aaron your walls uh yes your bottom of
the ocean that's what we're gonna be
talking about here okay so I have to
scan that and I have to get in there and
there's a lot of radiation I don't know
if this is gonna be like a finality type
thing but I just wanna oh this is open
now okay
Frick million-dollar [ __ ] gun well yeah
I guess that would be done now oh maybe
I have already been in here
yeah looks like maybe I have weird
what's over here suspect holding I know
I didn't need the cue beam for that but
it just felt satisfying who are there
who's in here
okay everything's fine
so much exotic material in this
particular lab okay I have a funny
feeling I am kind of leaning towards
blow it all up
that is what I'm leaning towards but you
never know in these things okay part of
the coral huh part of the coral what is
this going to do
come to the bridge we can finish this
thing once and for all
assume Alex's plan succeeds then what
you're taking a massive gamble that
there aren't more predators like the
titan in the history of the universe
humans have only recently become
self-aware yet you're going to kick the
door open on a much wider and older
cosmic ecology one that feeds on
consciousness these are shark-infested
waters Alex believes we can be the
bigger shark but what if we're just poor
swimmers and now there's blood in the
water
well okay that's not a very good that's
not a very good argument because you're
basically just saying like we can't risk
it therefore we don't explore but I
think what this reveals with that inject
more of Morgan's cell lines is I've got
to be fake like I've got to be fake I
have to be right there's no way like I'm
not real I'm not really Morgan you know
what I mean I'm not there's got to be
something else about that there's got to
be something else there I'm gonna go
thankfully that didn't zap me because I
don't have an a health back but I've
gotta be fake I've gotta be there's no
way I'm really Morgan or whatever that
means you know whatever like that the
end result of that is oh so I'm gonna go
down the reactor and then I'm gonna prep
that because apparently it's all
controlled from the bridge so you might
as well do both let me just see if it's
still an objective here yeah you can
access self to truck controls and I have
both the arming keys so there's no point
in not prepping it for that just to get
both sides of the argument here so down
to the reactor I go I think I get
through it from life support for some
reason I don't know why you have it
available Oh was there a medical officer
over here please tell me there was oh no
but Frick forgot about that thing I
don't know I don't just repair those
things it's time goes on because I'm a
dummy I'm a big dumb dummy dumb sell all
my spare parts for fricking mineral
materials even though I don't have any
frickin plant life all the plant life
has been scoured across this entire
station there's nothing left I kept
eating all the food so I guess but was
there
oh yeah that's what I wanted to do thank
you for that [ __ ]
there we go splay out what do we got and
put that in there put this in there and
those in this so we have something oh
yeah and the anti rattle for got about
that you know and I'll put that in there
too
who needs it maybe maybe just a split of
it how do I
and then blam I'm gonna make some med
kits cuz goddamn scribbled aboot okay oh
there's no fabricator in here yeah big
big yeah bang new okay whatever let's
get out of here we'll hit a fabricator
on the way I'm sure we will doodlee
doodlee doodlee do it's good here lady
let's get it later
it's good Italy I'm assuming the live
stop [ __ ] debo do I need to go down
there
yeah I'm assume that butyl II do yeah
it's down there alright so what I need
to do is I need a prep in and I'm sure
I'm sure maybe if you do both actually
know if he uses the null wave it's
probably gonna hit me super hard like
super super hard crazy hard here's a
crazy Theory does Alex even have a
brother is Morgan even really you know
in existence you know maybe they were
just doing that preparatory stage just
to say to try to ingrain that Morgan has
a backstory
you know treading grain is life that
they constructed here I don't know it
just seems also fabricated and maybe
everyone else is fooled too into
thinking that Alex has a brother and it
was all meant to be an emotional appeal
oh forgot about that one - Rick him not
doing well I got no help
ah boy oh boy here but maybe you know
maybe maybe maybe maybe maybe
ah okay but maybe maybe he fabricated
the whole brother thing just to make an
emotional appeal so that I would be you
know interested in actually helping him
and actually saving him what would have
happened if I'd to just let him die Oh
God so many different things it's super
weird there's so many questions and I'm
sure I'm gonna get answers soon but it
doesn't change the fact that I'm really
curious as to what's going on I just
kind of blast through here oh can you no
I don't need you you're fine you're fine
you're fine I hate not knowing I hate
being in the lurch what was even the
point of fixing up this coolant chamber
by the way I can't remember what the
point of that was Thanks
okay whatever you say man whatever you
say oh boy oh boy let me take one of
these and grab this
oh man this place is heavily defended oh
boy I'm gonna go back up done knock it
over okay I'm just gonna die I'm a
dinosaur
oh great [ __ ] hell
Oh medical officer tonight a medical
operator please thank you oh thank you
oh my God thank you okay well at least I
have the tools with which to fight these
guys now meaning health and if I
remember correctly a whole lot of this
well I'm gonna get out of here oh it's
canoodling whoa
okay did that that did a lot of damage -
whoa okay that's not enough parallel
good god it's insanity why were they all
picnic why why [ __ ] why okay so reactor
is way down there it's obviously the
harder to get to so I'm thinking that
maybe that's like a by design kind of
thing it's supposed to be this one
Oh get it go get it go come on come on
Oh okay gotta go back up oh hey what the
hell is this mouki receptacle all right
I'm just gonna arm it mmm that's all I'm
gonna do [ __ ] you are here all right
fine then so arming key arming key
activate activate boom
all right so those are armed so what if
that means I gotta go I gotta get all
the way back up but I gotta go yeah so
now that the options are open to me I'm
sure if I get to the bridge
people are gonna give some last
compelling arguments to either side if I
remember how to go correctly here which
I don't think I do no no no come on come
on come on go go go hurry come on it's
right there climb back it's right
[ __ ] hell are you oh my god are you
kidding oh my god
[ __ ] hell oh okay all right then
that's fine [ __ ] Jesus just um okay so
they [ __ ] up my entire landing here
but maybe that's for the best
ah why [ __ ] [ __ ] you man [ __ ] you son of
a [ __ ]
all right just let me climb my stupid
shaft oh come on
okay maybe this one's gonna work this
sack there we go
how did I climb this in such a blind
fury before there's no way that I would
have been able to survive this there's
no way I should have been able to
survive this
oh hello okay let's get Lee yeah all
right and where did I go before I can't
remember now up here maybe seems about
right
maybe get
okay oh we're going up at least that's
awfully nice
OOP Oh No
worst time worst time
Oh God No Oh
Rick okay there was another way to go I
know that I know I want another way the
the other time that I went up here I
know that so there's gotta be a way to
go up higher oh this is ridiculous
was it here oh okay okay it's here hi
what are you doing up here get down aah
come on
where am i okay okay seasons I'll fire
I remember that Burnham a crotch okay
gotta keep going though almost there yep
that's good up there up here over here
skadoodle
all right let bleep blorp
bibbidi-bobbidi-boo yeah
and we're here okay let's get out of
here now that we got all this [ __ ] out
of the way and we got both arm and keys
in there now we got the decision to make
at the bridge and I'm sure people are
gonna argue with me
either way and I don't know why doll
hasn't talked to me yet she should have
been talking to me way before cuz he's
gotta be over at his place by now Thanks
yeah I know and valuable and valuable
whatever the [ __ ] you say man how did I
get up there again I've totally
forgotten oh yeah I build myself a
staircase out of glue but efficiently
right at the end here I've run out of
blue who'd have thought it was even
possible that I could run out of glue
all right but here we go
I've got plenty of ammo for whatever
final battle that's got for me which I
know it's gonna do something with the
big guy up there are out there man so
the Typhon is weird because it obviously
has like a homeworld that's what I've
been seeing in Maya in my brain so it
could be the Typhon is telling me to
kill them all it could be that like that
could be the truth of it and maybe
blowing up this station is what it wants
me to do instead of what I should do you
know what I mean but then like am i a
Taifun or am i a human like that is the
big oh that's not what I wanted yeah
because if I'm a Typhon then I don't
really owe any whoa
going up going up I know there's a
fabricator down there which is what I
need but I don't have time because if
I'm a Typhon then I wouldn't have any
actual like loyalty I'm out of glue ah
[ __ ] it
Oh nearly
Oh woohoo okay
Boop and then boom okay so if I'm a
Typhon then I don't actually have any
loyalty but in my mind I would like
pocket whatever but in in my mind if
they're saying kill them all
maybe that's misleading in terms of like
saying blow it up and maybe it's just
the Typhon that are all like hey kill
all those humans we gotta kill them
they're so crazy and cool and whatever
and I don't know why is it my own voice
that's talking to me it's like you know
it ties into the Phantom's like do the
Phantom's even realize that their time
fun you know what I mean like do the
Phantom's even realize that they're not
human anymore
just like I wouldn't I wouldn't know if
I wasn't human anymore so what would be
the point of doing anything
there's the excellent question of all
[Music]
but I'm gonna make a decision soon
enough I gasps oh boy it's all gonna
come to a head no matter what I do so we
better get to it I think the bridge is
all the way up tippy-top II so that'll
be easy to get to Dallas one was
designed to rival the wonders of the
world
yeah sure wasn't I'm about to probably
blow it up
like maybe thankfully that's so glued up
okay
maybe okay now this is a weird one this
is a bit of a stretch where's the bridge
this is a bit of a stretch but maybe
maybe maybe overtime you know how it
seemed like I changed my mind about
things and I suddenly became like I have
to blow all this up maybe that was less
to do with me having a moral difference
but me being influenced by the Typhon
over time and holding to their
objectives more than my own originally
because it did seem like over time
Morgan and even my messages to myself
was like he changed his mind at first he
was all about doing this and then all
ascend he was like no we gotta blow up
the station we gotta blow it all up we
got to stop them researching the Typhon
it's too dangerous or something like
that which is what the Typhon would say
if they didn't want humans to discover
the seat been here before I don't even
remember being here and let me just I do
not know if I've been here before
uh-huh no wave device transmitted what
about the the blowy blowy uppy uppy
where's that one ah self-destruct is up
there no wave is down here no one's
gonna talk to me about it no one's gonna
give me any ideas about it one way or
the other no one has any opinions no I
don't think so is there a manual crank
of some sort Rimmer
was there never any intention of having
anyone escape this place one second let
me let me do a real save here a big-boy
save and then see what's going on in the
briefing room honestly who knows what is
going on here
this doesn't make any sense what's the
objective what's the end objective
cafeteria from 12:00 to 2:00 p.m. please
with
[Music]
super weird what is then objective huh
okay don't know what that was all about
but okay
ah [ __ ] god damn it I just had to slide
extra long then I all my slides thus far
have been really piddly slides but that
one no that one was the best
I don't know why I'm going up here by
the way I'm just trying to explore
everything oh that thing is big and
looks angry really angry now let me go
up there at least see what's going on
upstairs oh I did go here for the escape
pods oh okay hmm okay so upstairs
Who am I talking to
my name is January 23rd Morgan sorry
interrupt maybe yeah I see a person who
looks like woken you Morgan
be cautious your brother is unstable he
may not permit you to activate the
self-destruct also he's armed unstable
is that a joke operator you've let this
machine poison you did it tell you it's
not gonna let you off the station
go on Talent your brother is correct
when you destroy Talos 1 my directive is
to ensure that you perish along with it
but you already knew that it was your
idea no one in their right mind would
agree to such a lunatic plan not true
history is populated with examples of
self-sacrifice for the benefit of others
easy to say when it's not your skin
robot I'm sorry Morgan
you have no idea what that word means
I'm gonna put a stop to this nonsense
your brother is only stunned though
obviously once you activate the
self-destruct the point is moot you're
still going to activate the
self-destruct aren't you please recall I
am acting on your orders I don't know I
don't know Oh No
[Music]
I don't know I don't know I'm aware that
you prime the arming keys to destroy
Talos 1 so I find the activation of this
null wave transmitter station puzzling
the directives you gave me require I do
everything in my power to ensure you
destroy Talos 1 and all the typhoon
detonating the station safeguards the
earth and perhaps provides a small
measure of reparation you know how
neural mods are made the demand will
only increase in the future Alex and
visions many will die for the benefit of
a privileged few I won't relinquish
control of the terminal if you want to
activate the null ways you'll have to
kill me
oh don't know what to do Oh
ah I wanna [ __ ] I want to see both ends
I do do this I've never really trusted
January why did you kill December that
was the other thing
what whoo-hoo is December we never
answered that question
did we who the [ __ ] was December all of
the optional quests are gone I'm sorry
January I'll come back for you
that was a that was a Typhon screen by
the way just to put that out there
shuttle landing countdown Seattle what
what does that even mean what does that
mean I don't know what that means
there's a small amount of time here hang
on one second let me let me I'm gonna do
this one first just I'm gonna do this
I'm probably gonna end up doing both I
just want to know what this does
hey what is a newer model well it's both
an easy answer complicated what at the
same time it is the future today
more importantly our past today
this is the work Transtar does every
employee working together
it's immortality and it is beautiful
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa what hang on hang on a second wait
hold on there what hey
what wait a minute wait a minute wait
wait just hold on one goddamn second
here I what we're entering a hidden
location born
[Music]
let's finished how did it do activation
of the mirror neurons is promising
empathy quotient shows to be
exceptionally high probably thinks it
was dreaming and nothing mattered you're
assuming he thinks like us its life
depends on it ours too
it all comes down to the choices it made
it saved me from the cargo container I
would have suffocated otherwise it
installed multiple Typhon based neuromas
it could mean an instinctive return to
its old kind or an attempt to integrate
it to LHS but its most surprising at
whispering de well perhaps for purely
selfish reasons this at least in
principle enabled others to escape their
loss why I would have died without my
medication that wasn't easy that says a
lot I think about its heart can I say
that it has a heart then there was a man
in psychotronics Ingram would you let it
live
yeah server the next the situation in
the cargo bay was bad none of us would
have survived without its help and he
destroyed a large number of Typhon
across the station that has to be a good
sign
further is $14 attempt to use us as
hostages if it were one of my officers I
would give it a commendation general
what do you say it found me
it doesn't need to but it did I asked
her to stop volunteer 37 that was
dangerous no way to be sure but I think
it has a sense of retribution a lot of
humans controlled by the typhoon ended
up dead not that it was easy to avoid
but I think it's worth the risk in the
end he chose to activate the null wave
device why to preserve a typhoon
technology we can't really know what its
motives were for anything it did but we
have to make a choice you can hear us
can't you yeah I want to show you
something oh I am very glowy I'm a
Typhon oh I knew it
I think if no idea what's going on
though what you experienced was a
reconstruction based on Morgan's
memories
that's is the wall today we spent years
trying to put what you can do into us we
never tried putting what we can do into
you until now another bridge between our
species I need to know if you see us I
mean really see us take my hand if you
do wait no yeah we're gonna shake things
up like old times
[Music]
hi-yah
[ __ ] whoo
so I was half right I was half right I
never even considered the possibility
that oh that was all like a recreation
of Morgan's memories and they're running
it through the paces of this like
invasion [ __ ] so what happened was this
over here what what is what what is that
I don't know what that means
what would that do I have no idea man
let me try this one it's finished all
the directives you gave me have been
completed all except one when the
station detonates it will destroy the
apex - and every trace of technology
derived from it including you but you
know this already it was your idea after
all
the alien neural mods you carry would
pose an unacceptable risk to everyone on
earth if you returned
have a seat Morgan you might as well
enjoy the view in your final moments
what everything's fine I got one of the
escape pods working sure
Morgan something's wrong there's no time
trust me
I'll see you earth side what hey wait a
minute
can I take Alex with me I checked I
don't think this is gonna work but I'm
gonna I'm gonna try I'm gonna try oh
sorry sorry sorry sorry Alex
sorry no I'm sorry sorry please
oops clunk clunk clunk clunk kitty clunk
clunk oh boy this is weird
huh this is crazy huh can I run with you
no I can't
this seems to me seems to be uh limiting
me Alex I don't even know if I'm gonna
be able to carry you across the
threshold at this other place I didn't
even know if anything was gonna happen
after I hit that button it's so weird
it's so weird I guess not I guess not
god it's so weird so like what's weird
about is that this all is a fabrication
and I had every suspicion that it was
all a fabrication from the very
beginning you know but I didn't realize
to what level microgravity detective
[Music]
uh-huh I already done something there
I've already done something good to know
that you were punching equate oh that's
that's a nice hobby that you got there I
don't even know if I'm gonna make it to
the shuttlebay in time I've no idea if
I'm gonna make it I've only got like 45
seconds to get there and I don't think
with all the [ __ ] that's going on
here I don't think I have enough time
but I'm gonna try
hoo-boy Oh
so that was that was that was the
countdown that I saw okay I gotta go the
lobby oh do I have any I don't have any
bed kits or anything but I might just
barely make it I might just barely come
on back I get back
come on shouldn't have tried to drag
Alex there was a moot point moot point
moot point go go go go go oh oh that's
not a lot of time whew that's a lot of
time oh boy we got like seconds I don't
think I'm gonna make it oh I don't think
I'm gonna make it I'm definitely not
gonna make it oh my oh my oh well this
is probably bad boy open up open up I'm
here no no I'm here I made it fine
please evacuate
Talos 1 hi sit down okay
here we go
ready or not starting debark operations
pre-flight check is who gives a [ __ ]
hang on to your seat this would be a
rough ride thanks doll
[Music]
yeah
Oh blam oh I keep having this dream
you just keep having this dream that's
all you gotta say about that
so let's go to the hidden place again so
weird
it's finished how did it do activation
of the mirror neurons is promising
empathy quotient shows to be
exceptionally high probably thinks it
was dreaming and nothing mattered you're
assuming he thinks like us
it's life depends on it ours too it all
comes down to the choices it made it
saved me from the cargo container I
would have suffocated otherwise it
installed multiple Typhon based neuromas
it could mean an instinctive return to
its old guy or an attempt to integrated
dual natures but it's most surprising at
was sparing des while perhaps for purely
selfish reasons this at least in
principle enabled others to escape tell
us why retriever I would have died
without my medication that wasn't easy
that says a lot I think about its heart
can I say that it has a heart then there
was a man in psychotronics Ingram would
you let it live
yeah Samer
the next the situation in the cargo bay
was bad none of us would have survived
without itself and it destroyed a large
number of Typhon across the station that
has to be a good sign
further is $14 attempt to use us as
hostages if it were one of my officers I
would give it a commendation Danielle
what do you say it found me it didn't
need to but it did I asked it to stop
volunteer a37 that was dangerous no way
to be sure but I think it has a sense of
retribution a lot of humans controlled
by the Tyson that ended up dead not that
it was easy to avoid but I think it's
worth the risk
in the end it shows to destroy tell us
why why to protect that we can't really
know what its motives were for anything
it did but we have to make a choice you
can hear us
can't you yeah I want to show you
something
so this is pretty much exactly the same
as it was before
there is no coz all my choices
throughout are exactly the same what you
experienced was a reconstruction based
on Morgan's memories that's there's the
wall today we spent years trying to put
what you can do into us we never tried
putting what we can do into you until
now
you're the bridge between our species I
need to know if you see us I mean really
see us take my hand if you do so this is
where I'm just gonna do the other choice
I'm not happy about that I wouldn't
normally do that but just to see all the
possible outcomes to see there's nothing
that that's not canon is not canonized
as horrible that's a horrible horrible
way to go through all that lovely time
on Talos one I just end up killing Alex
oh my god okay so alright to wrap my
head around all this the intro the most
interesting thing about this whole game
is the fact that in the end in the end
your choices are a test it was a test to
see what it could do and I bet I bet at
the end of the game if you made really
bad choices like you killed everybody on
the way I made really [ __ ] choices like
that would be totally different than it
was in that instance and so in the end
your choice of blowing it up or using
the null wave transmitter is moot
because that already happened it was
what Morgan did originally on that
station that affected the universe that
they are in today they made that Typhon
have Morgan cells and then put it in a
virtual reality of Morgan's memories on
Talos one so what Morgan did is
different what I did as that Typhon as
the bridge between the species and in
the end there it it was that recreation
of it and putting me in that environment
and making me learn everything that was
really interesting because I just find
it fascinating it's like a duality to it
because it was really interesting it at
the same time being tested but also it
felt like my choices were a little bit
moot towards the end there because it
was all just a dream you know it's that
cliche where it's like oh it's all just
a dream and then it gives you that one
final choice to be like do I do I reject
your reality and substitute my own or do
I actually accept an act as a bridge
which is will one that I would pick the
one that I killed them is not the one
that I would have actually picked I just
did that so you guys could see the other
option which was horrible so anyway that
is the end of prey this was really
really cool I could go on for hours
probably talking about this and how cool
but I will leave it at that and I will
leave it to you guys to figure out the
rest of it for whatever you want it to
be so let me know what you think down
the comments below what is like
everything that I've missed in this
series what have I missed in here but
how cool this is this this was like a
long long game but I'm really really
glad that I played it through because
this was super fun from start to finish
it had so many openings and if you were
doing completionist I bet there's
probably like another secret ending
beyond everything if you did absolutely
everything like the right way or
absolutely everything the wrong way
because there were secrets in there that
I didn't fully unlock like that corpse
in the medbay
I never got in there to see that and I
really wanted to know the answer I
carried that tracking bracelet with me
through the whole game so you guys will
just have to figure it out for yourself
and or tell me down the comments below
so thank you everybody so much for
watching thank you for joining me on
another long let's play this has been a
fun fun time and I'm super happy that I
did this game so thanks again and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]